I'll I'll be honest with you when I was
in the agency for well you know again
going on two
decades I don't ever remember having a
political discussion we never sat in a
safe house and you could spend a lot of
time sitting in a safe house waiting for
something to pop right because you know
for whatever reason you know the
target's not available or you're waiting
for headquarters to say yeah let's do
it we never had conversations sitting
around talking politics it just wasn't a
thing right and the agency itself is is
always supposed to be apolitical I mean
it's human right so people are going to
have their opinions and that's fine you
but you know you keep it in check right
sure um and so obviously the rub now is
that that's not the case right both for
the agency and the bureau the bureau is
taking a real
kicking joining me today is a former CIA
officer a security expert and host of
the president's Daily Brief podcast
Mike Baker finally welcome to the Ruben
report thank you very much D appreciate
I'm glad to have you for a couple
reasons I see on Rogan I see on Gutfeld
all all the usual places podcast is
great uh but you're kind of doing me a
favor by being here today too because
I've been doing a lot of racehorse
politics a lot of primary who's going to
win battle it out all of that stuff and
I'm actually really looking forward to
taking a little bit of a break from that
and talking mostly about war yeah good
lighten it up a little bit several
impending Wars
that's right the world's on fire so
let's cheer people up uh can you tell
people just briefly before we dive into
all that cuz and I normally don't even
keep notes in front of me but I was like
there's a lot of places on this planet
that are a flame right now and I want to
make sure we don't miss any of them yeah
that's exactly right but before we get
to any of that can you just give people
a little more of your background for
someone that that may not know who you
are and then we'll and then we'll dive
in sure um yeah I you know I was with
the agency the CIA
for about 20 years going on 20 years and
I was in what they call the director of
operations so the agency has broken up
into different segments right you have
operations you have the director of
intelligence they change the names
occasionally but basically it's always
the same four groups and the Intel
directory that's where all the smart
people are and they write the reports
they take all the intelligence they take
everything that's coming in right and
you have the really smart writers the
analysts all those people and then they
have a uh an admin essentially section
that does all the logistics and they
really keep the place running because
it's not like just admin for say a
company that's making widgets right
you're you're running Intel operations
around the world so it's it's a bit of a
different game and then there's the
Science and Technology Group and they
make all the amazing gadgets right so
think about um well I can that despit on
a rabbit hole on that one Battery tech
are you wearing any of those things I am
as a matter of fact I never traveled
without a couple of gadgets but they uh
you know everything from Spy satellites
to the YouTu program uh back Battery
Technology if anybody's walking around
with a defibrillator right they can
thank the agency because they they led
the way in terms of miniaturization
right because you needed small batteries
for operational reasons right um but I
was in the director of operations and
spent all my time overseas which was
great um had a wonderful time got out
started a a private sector company that
does um uh basically intelligence and
security risk mitigation it's Portman
Square group and we're now I take it
that's probably going pretty well these
days it's gone things happening in the
world I think you know it sounds
mercenary but we do well when there's a
little bit of chaos um and we most of
our work is is is overseas you know we
do we do a fair amount in the States but
the majority is overseas and we've got
offices in a number of places uh great
people it's been a wonderful experience
cuz I had no business experience at all
none and so when it came time to get out
of the agency because I was raising my
daughter um I had to do something right
and I didn't really have a lot of skills
so I thought well I'll stay in what I
know and it worked out I started it with
a a wonderful friend of mine who came
from the British teams and uh we just
got really lucky and we met wonderful
people and we best thing we did was we
hired smart people right and then we
gave them the the objective and then we
set them on their way right and that was
that's there's a a few things I learned
from the agency
and one of them was was essentially that
right bring on the best people you can
tell them what the mission is and then
have the confidence that they're going
to get on with it right and now if
things go south okay then you got to
step in and help out but so we've been
fortunate we've done that and then I I
got involved in some some TV work and
and some film work um the podcast has
been great we just started that in
September the president's Daily Brief
whole new experience I give you a a
tremendous amount of credit because it's
it's not easy right it's a lot of
gadgets mostly
hairspray well I'm going through an
awful lot of glitter and lip balm uh but
no it's it's it's an audio podcast right
now they they're turning it into a into
a video podcast um but it's it's a lot
of work so I you know I take my hat off
to you but uh it's been fun so let me
ask you a little bit more about uh the
agencies in general because I've talked
to a couple XC obviously FBI Etc and I
always find it interesting when you when
you talk to some of these guys who are
out in terms of how much they can talk
about and how they can take the stuff
that they learned and apply it to either
new businesses or just kind of what's
going on in the world without without
breaking protocol without revealing
Secrets Etc how do you how do you
balance all that stuff well you know
what um you have to be smart enough to
know what you're not supposed to say
right and then you have to be
disciplined enough not to to open your
Yap and and and do that so sources and
methods you never talk about I've got a
very good relationship with the agency I
think in part because they they know I
respect them I had a great time right
I'm not one of those people who left and
and and talks bad about right because I
had I just had a great time I was lucky
in that sense right and had worked for
amazing people and and worked with
people that were tremendous um and so as
long as you understand what you are not
supposed to say right and you sign
secrecy agreements and those secrecy
they don't have a a shelf life right you
know it's it's not as if okay it's 10
years on now I can now go on TV and you
take that the whole thing so you take
that to your grave and you need to
respect that right um so and the agency
they they were very good to me right
when I left because you know the their
point was well don't leave you know at
first they was they were sort of like
don't leave cuz what else are you going
to
do I mean look at you uh so but I mean
they me it in a kind way you know and
then when I did go to leave they said to
the degree that we can you should leave
and be able to say that you were here
right and so that's a process in itself
and I didn't really realize the value of
that at the time because I didn't you
know again no business experience so
getting out um and being able to do that
that opened some doors that I hadn't
really anticipated and so that was a
very good thing how different do you
think the agency is now the CIA
specifically from when you were involved
because my guess is 20 years ago there
was a I don't want to speak for you but
there was probably a certain level of
trust in the institution that now at
least from the outside seems Seems let's
say shaky at best yeah yeah there's a
lot of that's a real yeah that that's a
real problem
um I'll I'll be honest with you when I
was in the agency for well you know
again going on to
decades I don't ever remember having a
political discussion we never sat in a
safe house and you could spend spend a
lot of time sitting in the safe house
waiting for something to pop right
because you know for whatever reason you
know the target's not available or
you're waiting for headquarters to say
yeah let's do
it we never had conversations sitting
around talking politics it just wasn't a
thing right and the agency itself is is
always supposed to be apolitical I mean
it's human right so people are going to
have their opinions and that's fine you
but you know you keep it in check right
sure um and so obviously the rub now is
that that's not the case right both for
the agency and the bureau the bureau's
taking a real kicking yeah and and I
think that's a real shame because
everybody I know including at the bureau
um and these are operators right these
are the agents at the bureau These Are
the officers at the at the uh
CIA they're they're terrific right and
they're not political and they and they
just do what they're supposed to do
right and the agency's job is very
simple right you protect the the
interests of the national uh of of of
the nation you know National Security
concerns and the administration tells
you what are your
priorities uh whichever Administration
is in charge and then you just march on
and do it right but obviously the rub is
now it's become a political
organization I would argue the same
thing that's been argued about the
bureau which is that takes place at a
much higher level right and you know the
director uh that's a political position
essentially a OED by the president
and yeah you can get a director who's
who's too enamored with politics with
too enamored with being at the White
House too enamored with that you know
the tightness of of that relationship
and and what it means uh you can get
others too who are you know more senior
but I can't speak for now but I can
speak for when I was there yeah it
wasn't a political organization and you
understood that because we spent our
time in some real holes overseas
right in some very difficult
environments where where the tradition
was if the government was overthrown and
they seem to be getting overthrown a lot
then next thing you know they just sweep
out the military they'd sweep out the
Intel organization whatever the
organization they had and they'd install
their buddies their friends those that
they knew were be Rock Solid loyal and
you see how awful that was and what it
would mean to the that that particular
country and so you know you had a real
understanding that that was never to
happen with the agency so yeah I think
we have to always be on guard about that
but the best way to to guard against
it unfortunately is to have a very uh
proactive and curious and demanding um
oversight by the uh Intel committees up
on Capitol Hill and unfortunately I say
unfortunately because my theory is we
really don't send our best and brightest
to Capitol Hill right so there's a
couple prong problem here it's sort of
politics have been injected into the
agencies and then the oversight
committees obviously the congressional
oversight committees as you said these
are not the best and the brightest so do
you think there's anything that can be
done to bring some of that trust back I
mean especially on the Republican side
now you're hearing candidates say you
know just blow away the agencies all
together and and a whole bunch of other
stuff what would what would look at like
a sort of sane Reformation as these
things have become political yeah yeah I
I hear that talk when people say we got
to fire them all you know whether
they're talking about the agency they're
talking about the FBI whatever or just
shut it down you think you know look
okay you're obviously too stupid right
to represent anybody you how did you
possibly get up on Capitol Hill no look
there's some very bright people I know
couple of the people on the on the Intel
committees that are super smart one of
them from from Idaho U Senator R right
they're some very good people but we
also have some morons right so I don't
want to paint them all with the same
brush but um I think what would a what
would a logical step
be I think I think one of the things
that needs to be done is that the after
9/11 they created you know the dni
position right and they they basically
collapsed everything into one
organization from the Intel Community
right all the various Intel agencies and
the CIA director was kind of pushed to
the side right in favor of the dni who
then you know sort of had that job of
sitting in the White House more it's
important to have a better line of
communication between the director of
the agency and the Oval Office right
now you know you can well make the
argument that it just depends on the
President right because some presidents
are better at at that relationship they
pay more attention you know there was
always the rub on on Trump that he
didn't read uh the uh the briefings that
came in um others read every page right
it just depends on the person but I
guess my point is I think one of the
problems we've got is is we don't have a
better line of communication between the
agency directly and and the Oval Office
it's too important an organization
particularly in today's Times um to
relegate it to just a member of the
Intel Community um otherwise I think
that you've got to have better vetting
of the senior leadership right in terms
of when they're appointed right and that
again is job of the Intel committees
Congress and
Senate and then like I said once you get
below that senior level people are just
doing their job they honest to God don't
give a who's in charge just you
know on the professional level just tell
us what the hell the mission is do do
you have any sense of how much Dei has
infected that level that the level that
you're saying is pretty solid because my
guess is that would be the level that
would get hit the hardest it's been hit
yes and and it's there right they've
they've done what everybody else has
done right they played the game of of
Dei and um I've seen a couple of the
recruiting ads that they've run um look
uh the agency was an old boy Network
right kind of the original days after
World War II it was very much like a y
operation right Ivy Leagues and somebody
get a tap on the shoulder and then be
recruited and yes you got a very
homogeneous looking group you know um so
but from an operational perspective you
want a real mix right so rather than
being told that we're doing this because
it you know makes the world a better
place from a Dei perspective I'd rather
see the director instruct everyone
saying we operate all around the globe
and we better blend in right in this
case there are reasons want people in
different col different langes exactly
exactly it's a perfect reason you don't
have to play the Dei game because you
need to have that operational you know
diversity and and so you know to me you
know having an equity officer or a Dei
you know director or whatever is is is
just it's nonsense right just
do your job which is get out there and
hire the best and brightest to operate
around the globe right and yeah I I
don't know it's it's you raised an
interesting point with it if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
nonstop screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell